seeing how it presents itself we can be
a little pessimistic but not
all the cards have been
given and I believe that we must
continue, we really must
go to the end and
like here in terms of the CGT position
I believe  that we must
always block what we must
try to always show our
disagreement
over a period of time I don't know until when
but we must still continue and do
the maximum to call into question
this time the reform has passed
but it  has still not been accepted
by the people it has never been accepted
by the people neither by nor by the Assembly
itself because there was indeed a vote
for whom for to try to have it
banned which did not succeed  but
it is different from a vote to have it
accepted and the reform passed without
our without our democracy and it is
important to make the
government understand that we never wanted to
reform and that and that and  that the teeth
all the same that the people that the
people speak because it is also
necessary that the government has
more and more nothing to do with the
words of the people and therefore it is important
that we  try to regain
power at this level you still have
hope that this reform will be
I still have hope because we
are still very mobilized despite despite
the passage of time and I think that I
think that  it's important to remain so
French president